ragazzi allora è da un pò di giorni
impegno tempo che li qualche giorno che
penso che vi devo questo video so che
sembra un po il discorso a mattarella
alla nazione però e non riuscite a fare
già dal titolo avrete capito un pochino
di cose e inutile che ci gira troppo
attorno mi sono stufato punto mi sono
stufato io guardo i video che pubblico
che in corso di tub e mi rompe il cazzo
meno per cazzo di quello che vedo che
fanno le persone e temi e ai video
cemento sul mio canale e piano vedo
proprio nella luce della felicità più
impero se ne va dai miei occhi e finisce
nella tomba
c'è una cosa che mi sono detto che
quella di essere non tanto per forza
onesto con tutte le persone che mi
stanno attorno ma almeno me stesso non
sono soddisfatto contento non mi
riconosco nei contenuti che stanno
uscendo il mio problema è legato a
youtube
io amo troppo questa piattaforma per
volerla relegare a un contenitore dove
si produce per produrre ma poi in realtà
di base si prosegue con il pilota
automatico fame lo aveva fatto non è il
motivo per cui a lezione youtube in modo
in cui sto lavorando su youtube non è un
modo che mi rappresenta
ecco io vorrei tornare come dicevo a
essere orgoglioso di quello che è che
posto almeno io non dovete esserlo per
forza anche voi spero possiate ma allo
stesso tempo voglio tornare essere
libero perché i brand a volte mettono
dei legacci che bloccano completamente
questo tipo di libertà youtube non è un
posto che io ho mai vissuto un posto
all'interno del quale fare soldi e
potrei e quando lo faccio funziona di
meno quando non lo faccio sto meglio io
voglio impegnarmi al fine di favorire la
qualità alla quantità prendere una pausa
vada posto cioè non è che scompaiono ci
saranno magari degli shorts più leggeri
su instagram
non è che sparirò per far vedere il
guscio deluso la spiaggia tutte quelle
cose si fanno su instagram comunque però
io ho bisogno di ritrovarmi un pochino
non so se capita anche a voi io ormai
dal prossimo che becco che mi fa
cos'è smog dal cero rais regionale
browser questo cazzo questa è la model
face tutto tu oppure ai set 8 5 anni che
include perché sempre più piccoli ormai
appena partoriranno gli faranno fare
talking to you down e fanno degli occhi
non ce la faccio
è tutto troppo uguale e che sia chiaro è
sono il primo a esserne c divertito e
sono il primo che puntualmente mi si
divertirà un ragazzo con questa roba qui
che ho un amore troppo grande per questa
piattaforma per trasformarla in un posto
nel quale opposto tanto per postare i
tubi è un posto fluido è un posto nel
quale si può sperimentare un posto nel
quale ci si può far conoscere perché
siamo davvero in ciò che va di moda e
ciò che tutti gli altri seguono e che
fanno un posto all'interno del quale si
può trovare una propria voce perchè io
in passato l'ho trovata e vorrei
continuare ad utilizzarla non tanto per
parlare di essa che cosa ma per poter
parlare a volte mi sembra capace che mi
esce non si sa manco la mia
ultimamente so tragico e lo dico subito
io voglio potermi meritare la vostra
attenzione
non voglio che sia uno storico di
affetto che mi porti a guardare nei
contenuti
voglio che sia un genuino interesse ma
che deve prima cosa a partire da me
quello che sto dicendo che voglio andare
in una direzione nuova
non ho ancora una risposta ma molto
probabilmente tante delle cose che avete
visto
non ci saranno più magari il posto della
roba che voi l'ha guardata ed è
adiacente vi mancheranno i momenti più
bassi del mio canale
però voglio almeno essere felice io e
alcuni di questi test sono state
trascinate prosciugate troppo a lungo e
poi spremere un limone fino ad un certo
punto
quindi io mi hanno scritto delle cose
che non ho seguito che non seguirò
quello che voglio dirvi se ringraziarvi
perché sento veramente di avere
all'interno di questo posto delle
persone che ci sono e che mi apprezzano
e chi apprezza soprattutto lavoro di
tutte le persone che sono dietro un
video che tanto e sono tante ma allo
stesso tempo voglio chiedervi scusa
facendogli una promessa io a volte ho
utilizzato il sono cresciuto come scusa
per raccontarmi il perché non avevo più
la stessa passione che aveva all'inizio
su determinate cose ci sono anche
raccontato il sono maturato per anche in
un certo senso giustificare delle scelte
più caute che ho fatto
ecco basta scuse vorrei tornare a essere
la prima persona orgogliosa di postare
un mio video
farò del mio meglio spero che questa
cosa si possa leggere che possa piacere
anche a voi per cui io vi auguro di
trascorrere questo mese al meglio io
farò di tutto per far sì che ciò accada
e ci rivediamo a settembre con quello
che arriverà non lo so manco io questa
cosa mi casa per una volta posso dire
questa cosa di casa e di più non so che
dire ciao